on today's safe state we're talking
about halo we're also talking about
ghost of tsushima and the witcher not
the game but the show
i'm kurt davina welcome it's monday july
27th hope you had a good weekend
now we finally saw what halo infinite
looked like last week and there's a
bunch of stuff there's a grappling hook
there's apparently co-op
and it's cross generations so thankfully
343 industries is clearing up some of
those points and
first one is the grappling hook which
the head of designer
named jerry hook gave some details on he
said quote master chief is not
spider-man that is not at all what the
grapple shot
does now as we saw in the gameplay last
week master chief uses to get closer to
enemies
pull explodey barrels to them get up to
higher ledges
it's also going to be a multiplayer but
it's going to be an item that you have
to find though
it would be pretty sweet to just do an
only grappling hook mode don't know what
that looks like
but you should consider it i'm giving my
idea something welcomingly coming back
to halo is a split screen co-op now
there is gonna be four player co-op but
that is gonna be reserved for online
only there's also no word whether or not
we're gonna get a competitive
split screen multiplayer mode we'll see
and of course this was controversially
taken out of halo 5 so
good on you dudes for bringing it back
keeping it on the couch
that's good we can play online but we
should also be able to play with friends
that we ski though we don't see them
often now but in the case
you live with someone that's cool halo
infinite is going to be a cross
generation release between the xbox one
and xbox series x so
of course it's there's some of us a
little skeptical on whether or not
the game is going to be compromised in
any way because of that but the studio
had chris lee
says otherwise he said quote from the
very beginning we wanted to make sure we
were developing all of these
expectations in parallel
and had the right technology to power
those experience and optimize them for
each device
but of course we'll get the true answer
to all these things when it comes out
this holiday
for the xbox series x it goes to
tsushima's got an update and it's adding
a variety of difficulty options
it's harder difficulty known as lethal
mode makes its enemies
hit harder but interestingly enough you
also hit harder
however the enemies are going to be way
more aggressive and the window to perry
and dodge
is going to be much much smaller then
they added a lower intensity mode that
lets you block some unblockable attacks
interrupt brute attacks and heal without
enemies attacking you enemies
also end their combos after they damage
you along with the difficulty options
they also added some extra accessibility
options for the subtitling like
changing the size and color so that's
pretty dope thanks for doing that
everyone's favorite bathing
silver-haired man
already got his own show on netflix
called the witcher and not only is that
getting a second season but we're also
getting a prequel series called blood
origins
the witcher blood origin is gonna be a
six part live-action limited
series set 1200 years before the regular
show
that means it takes place before the
conjunction of the spheres
when the human elven and monster worlds
were all still
separate and it will include the origin
of the very first witcher
now the second season the witcher was
put on hold due to the state of the
world but
it's reportedly gonna start filming
again soon now blood origins is still in
development so there's no release date
yet but it's a thing
[Music]
okay that's it for news but we still
have one more order of business
gamespot has its own merch store the
place in which you can buy a poster
t-shirts a hoodie and this skateboard
and until the end of august all of its
proceeds will be going to both black
lives matter and
coven 19 relief so there will be a link
in the description below you can get a
face mask and some other things so
check it out okay that's it for today's
episode of course you can find out
about everything i just talked about and
more by going to gamespot.com
again i'm kurt davina be well play video
games
like what you like share what you like
be cool about stuff that other people
like
okay see you later yo
check this out